talk to me about the you know really
long term vision 10 plus years from now
where does this go and kind of how does
it evolve
yeah when i get asked questions like
that it's so tempting for me to just be
like well
we all live in the secret citadel
obviously uh
no it's it's a really interesting
question because it really depends what
happens to the world like
if the world changes over the next five
to ten years dramatically so i think
it's changed pretty dramatically in the
last eight months
um but like look look over the next like
decade what are the trends you think are
going to occur
globally and so one of those trends as i
was saying is what is going to be the
role of nation states versus
corporations
what does that mean for self-sovereignty
and these decentralized networks
my thesis has always been that we're
going to see
more and more of a pull to these sort of
user-centric networks that are user
owned user controlled
you know not not in an isolating way not
in like
i tore him alone but just like i tore as
an individual contributing within this
community in this context
now have more ownership and more control
of the
organizations that i choose to use on a
daily basis
so if that's a trend we're going to see
over the next five to ten years globally
i know that secret network's going to
have a huge role to play in that
but if we just take like the world of
today
and much like you know it used to be
like uh you know
if people had thought about what's the
henry ford quote or whatever he was like
if
you'd asked people what they wanted they
would have said faster horses kind of a
thing so let's take that for a second
you take the world of today and we just
say well where can secret network plug
into like the enterprise world today
i would say privacy is one of the key
things that's preventing enterprise
adoption of the public blockchain
ecosystem
so even just looking in the next few
years thinking about how can secret
networks start onboarding
more of these enterprises into our
universe and
there's so much that you can do with
secret network just around like secure
data sharing
if you're a bank with branches in
multiple comp in multiple countries
and you need to share user data securely
across you know
international lines because you're doing
some sort of fraud detection algorithm
like what a like what a simple like real
world use case but possible with our
network you don't have to go into like a
decentralized lending platform with you
know
sushi farming or whatever's in vogue
these days like that's just like a
regular real world use case or like for
example
healthcare since we're in the middle of
a pandemic enigma built
uh this this product called safe trace
and it's privacy preserving contact
tracing and contact tracing was a big
topic earlier this year thinking like if
i've been in contact with an
infected individual i want to know at
the same time
i don't want to tell everybody in the
world my infection status i don't want
to tell the government exactly where i'm
located at all times
so i know built this poc to be able to
say here's a way to do secure
contact tracing and they're actually now
working with intel
to like get that scaled out and and
bring it to market in a more robust
sense
things like that can be deployed on
secret network right or they could be
deployed like
privately as well but i think that
applications like that are much more
useful
and in the long run probably the way
that we all want to be going like
those are the kinds of applications that
you want to be decentralized community
owned and so on so that you
so that you can ensure that they're not
held in the hands of like a single
government that could misuse that data
so there's there's the like 10-year
vision of like our is the world going to
collapse
i don't know but even if it doesn't
there's a ton of ways that i think this
technology is relevant
today that i can't wait to get started
uh you know building just because it'll
help expand what's possible with these
technologies versus
the insular world we've lived in for the
for the past few years
what needs to happen uh kind of outside
of your own efforts
right in terms of the the network and
the community uh to facilitate this or
accelerate right so what like the macro
forces or things that can
be tailwinds uh to get there faster
well i would say that education is a
huge piece of this and not just
education of end users but mostly
education of the governments and
enterprises
who to date really don't show any
concrete understanding of how a lot of
the stuff works
i would say education also of
tax systems and the irs and things like
that like if people start to understand
like
there's no way to put our crazy square
peg crypto universe in the in the round
holes of traditional regulation like
we're not out here to do anything crazy
obviously some people are but and to
take advantage of people
like privacy is kind of the opposite
we're here to protect people
if we can help the governments and
enterprises and regulators of the world
sort of understand that privacy is about
protecting the same people that they're
trying to protect
and we get the tailwind of that sort of
support and adoption
from various entities all over the world
i think that would go a
huge way towards supporting like our
reach to try to
onboard like the long tail of users onto
these decentralized applications so long
as they see it as a direct threat maybe
to their authority
it becomes a lot more impossible and i
think that there is you know a tendency
in the crypto space to position
ourselves
against the traditional world and say
like okay
we're external we're revolutionaries you
know we have to be
you know reactive to every everything
else that's going on in the world
and i just don't think we'll ever get
global adoption
if that's our attitude and and the
reason we have to have an attitude
adjustment
is we can't allow ourselves to
you know be left out of the conversation
because if you leave it up to the
surveillance states of the world
like we will end up in the dystopia that
we don't like and if we're if we're just
going to bury our heads in the sand and
try to say
we're going to build a parallel universe
we don't need the regulators to
understand we don't need the enterprises
to understand
then they're going to build something
without us too and then at the end of
the day
we live in a meat space like we're going
to have to live in their world so unless
we learn to work together and play nice
with the rest of the world
until we can all start living in virtual
reality paradises like
we have to understand that this has real
world consequence and we have a
responsibility to make sure the real
world that's getting built
is the one that we want to live in
what do you think the um
things that could happen that would
change your mind
in terms of this is where we're going
in terms of this is where we're going
when i'm saying like which which part
the part where i'm hopeful that
everything works out for the best and we
do integrate with normal society or the
part where
uh i i'm wrong and everything burns down
uh the idea that you have of like
hey the world is going in the wrong
direction what could happen that would
change your mind on that
yeah honestly what i want to see
is world leaders you know whether you're
a leader of corporations or whether
you're a leader of a financial
institution
or a leader of a country people stepping
up and seeing
saying i see the value in these
technologies for the people i am
responsible to
you know like if you're in a financial
institution it's like we have investors
we have people who have like given us
their capital protect
like for people like that to say like
bitcoin is now my treasury asset
that goes a long way uh for for somebody
who runs the government to be able to
say we are working with the creators of
these decentralized technologies to
build these privacy preserving
applications for our citizens
because we believe this is the best way
to protect our citizens like
people listen to people in positions of
authority
and when right now when we look at the
world i see a lot of people in positions
of authority that i don't
really want to listen to at all because
they just don't understand the
fundamentals of the technologies maybe
that they're talking about but also a
lot of them just don't seem to have the
best interests of the people they're
supposed to protect
in their mind if we get to a point in
the world where
we have had some sort of like on the
ground revolution and now
our governments do seem to reflect the
will of users or our enterprises our
corporations
do seem to exist to protect users and
here's where i think or i hope
apple's moving in the right direction
versus a facebook
like if that's the trend of the world if
we start seeing leaders step up and say
we know this is best for our users
then i'll feel a lot more hopeful
because then i know they'll be
considering all kinds of solutions and
up until that moment what i'll assume is
that they're all behind the scenes
uh trying to collect as big of a facial
recognition database as possible
and that's you know that would be the
downside that's the scary scenario
that's the thing i have to stay scared
of because it's what gets me up in the
morning to keep trying to build out what
we're trying to do